hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of the Walking Dead Season
nine episode 12 titled Guardians this
episode explores a society the whispers
it lets Daryl continue to be the clever
hero we both deserve and need right now
even if Lydia gave us the most heroic
moment of the hour this was yet another
fascinating episode rich with character
details connections to the comics that
you might have overlooked and I'm gonna
break it all down who are there warning
in case you haven't seen the episode yet
and real quick before I begin thanks to
Philo for sponsoring this video
stick around at the end of this video to
learn how you can start watching
episodes of The Walking Dead within
seconds and a special offer just for you
guys the first 50 of our new rockstars
fans to sign up using our link below
will get their first month for free get
on that
okay this episode begins with the
whisperers returning from the hilltop
with alphas daughter Lydia returned to
the pack and right away we should talk
about the music that Walking Dead
composer Brer McCreary wrote for the
whisperer theme now here it sounds like
McCreary is using a stringed instrument
maybe a mandolin and the effect is
subtle in chili kind of like the sound
of a haunted forest the delicate
plucking of the strings evokes the way
that the whisperers use strings laces
and wires as tools and weapons and
speaking of threads this opening
exchange between alpha and Lydia reveals
a major loose thread that sets up a big
twist later in the episode remove your
skin what I like to try
Lydia is saying that Daryl still
possesses the Walker skin mask that he
took off of her a few episodes back
obviously it's important because Daryl
has a useful way to cloak himself among
the whisperers the way they cloak
themselves among the walkers and
naturally he uses his device at the end
of the hour
Lydia then confirms that there are
actually far far more whispers than the
you that she's old Daryl about and then
she says something interesting to her
mom no weapons are basic
but not enough any signs of trade
but notice how Lydia averts her eyes and
she seems less confident because she is
straight-up lying to her mother remember
Henry confirmed to her in episode 10
that other communities beyond this
hilltop do exist allies that they have
shared resources with and on top of this
although Lydia might not know it a lot
of this more recent technology that the
hilltops using was actually given to
them by another community the mysterious
place that Georgie came from and by the
way I actually think that's where Maggie
and Herschel might have gone to after
whatever went down between the
communities during this six year time
gap I just said because Maggie seemed to
get along fairly agreeably with Georgie
during that meet and greet anyway this
episode was adapted loosely from issue
139 in the comics when Karl follows the
whispers and then gets discovered and
Karl has brought to their camp not Henry
and Daryl's use of the whisper masks to
infiltrate the camp is actually a move
that the character Dwight used an issue
159 overall I gotta hand it to the show
for the way that they've adapted the
whisperers storyline casting the makeup
the gore the music the entity and the
camerawork all these elements have come
together really well to emphasize the
pure horror that this group represents
especially when in the comics the
whisperers were more of a good concept
that wasn't really that well executed a
good example of this is alpha
second-in-command beta in the comics
beta doesn't get introduced until way
later and he's kind of a wasted
character but here the show brings him
in right away and they cast Ryan Hurst
in the role he might know Hurst from
Sons of Anarchy or Bates Motel
personally I know best is Gary Bertier
from Remember the Titans yeah that dude
with the horn and we see how beta is the
expert tracker of the whispers the loyal
get straight talkin counselor honestly
he's a lot like Daryl I look forward to
seeing these two square off actually a
theory about that I'll get to that at
the end of the video beta proves his
loyalty to alpha by defending her when
she gets challenged by Shaun and Helen
who feel betrayed by alphas decision to
trade their two prisoners for her one
daughter the whisperers pack hierarchy
allows for lower ranking members to
challenge the Alpha but this is a common
thing among all societies it's actually
the third time the Walking Dead is
underlined the resolve of a villain with
a threat from a rival challenger
remember last season Simon challenged
negan with Meighan holding on to his
alpha status and back in season five
those Hospital
cops remember them there was a challenge
between dawn and o'donnell that ended
with Beth kicking him down the elevator
shaft
so Alpha and Beta take care of these
mutineers really it was the moment after
the challenge that revealed how dark
alpha truly is she told beta a story
about how before the outbreak three year
old Lydia got tangled up in a
dry-cleaning bag and almost suffocated
alpha said she watched her toddler
nearly died and then slapped it out of
her
and all this what to prove a point -
come on Lady you didn't need to let her
blackout just that first breath blocked
by the plastic would have definitely
been horribly traumatic for a kid so
yeah I don't think we should buy this
whole survival of the fittest philosophy
from alpha because again in nature
mothers instinctively protect their
young from harm even when it's a
teachable moment there's definitely
something wrong about alpha apparently
even before the outbreak began and this
I suppose made her harder and tougher
for this post-apocalyptic world but
here's a twist I'll throw out yet what
if alpha is lying to beta here look the
only proof we've seen of her cruel past
is from Lydia's flashback and those
scenes were presented to us from the
eyes of an unreliable narrator says
Lydia was lying to Darryl and Henry now
it's safe to say that alpha was
definitely a sadist post outbreak we
just have no proof that she was a Casey
Anthony pre outbreak and it could all be
a front like the false personae that
Carolyn Ezekiel had displayed a way for
alpha to instill fear and maintain her
alpha status but it's not clear how well
this feared not loved guardianship works
on Lydia because notice this moment
between them when alpha brings up what
she did to her father you know what
happened to him yeah I know she called
her mother savage Lydia knows that
addressing her mother as anything other
than alpha will get her a slap so what
we are seeing here is true defiance the
title of this episode is guardians and
we see how alphas parental philosophy
compares to the guardianship of Michonne
and Daryl Michonne is less trusting
initially she wields her veto power over
the Alexandria council to stop any
outreach effort still shaken from
Jesus's death and from whatever happened
in the past but then she interrogate
sneak in after his whole furlough back
in episode 9 and it leads to this great
exchange with Judith
but people don't really change you did
Korea room tonight convinces Michonne
that the best way to guard a society is
to trust it to make its own choices like
sending a delegation to that big fair at
the kingdom that will probably be a big
disaster because this is still the
walking dead and no major upcoming event
gets talked about with this much concern
without some horrible consequences on
the way but Daryl also plays a guardian
role this episode he joins Connie and
dog still working on fetch and arrows
without snapping them in a mission to
rescue Henry using Lydia's masks to
blend in and lead walkers into the West
Spurs camp so after this very smart
tactic why does Daryl make the
boneheaded move of tossing the mask
behind rather than keep it use again
potentially like surely this master
tracker must know that the whispers will
find Lydia's old mask and know exactly
who attacked their camp this leftover
smoking gun is the final image of the
episode and I think dropping it behind
it was a deliberate move by Daryl for
him it's a calling card he wants the
whispers to know who hit them because he
hates these abusive animalistic baby
killers he wants to piss him off drag
him out of the shadows elevate their
whispers to angry screams so that he can
take him out and eliminate this threat
because that's the kind of Guardian
Daryl is so my question for you between
Daryl Michonne and alpha which do you
think is the most effective Guardi in
this episode comment down below with
your thoughts and thanks again to philo
who sponsored this video and made a
return weekly coverage of The Walking
Dead possible
Philo is a streaming service with over
50 channels including the AMC Comedy
Central Annie it's really the easiest
way to watch The Walking Dead you can
start watching episodes within seconds
and there's unlimited recording so that
you can save as many shows as you want
Philo's available on Apple TV Roku
Android iOS and fire TV it's simple it's
affordable it's only $20 a month for all
this content you can essentially save
$100 a month on your cable bill pilo is
your best solution to stay cord free and
commitment free eight it's a special
offer just for you guys the first 50 new
rock stars fans to sign up using our
link will get their first month for free
visit wwii low T V / new rock stars
that's pH Aiello TV slash new rock stars
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
a vos it subscribe to this channel new
rock stars on YouTube and subscribe to
our podcast where we listen to podcasts
thanks for watching bye